all right why should women shouldn't
vote yes yes okay a lot of people think
I'm insane because I don't think women
should vote everybody thinks I'm crazy
for this opinion if anything this is
probably my most extreme opinion and I
would like to tell you how I came to
this conclusion so what happened was I
wanted to know why men were so angry
about women why are there all these
complaints about women and when I
started researching the stuff it was
pretty easy to figure out why ninety
percent of women have been on birth
control one out of three women has had
an one out of three women has an STD
um the average body count is over five
so that your average wife has slept with
over five people 95 of what percent 95
percent of women are not virgins on
their wedding days so I understand the
complaint now I understand okay the
quality of women but I kept thinking why
so this is the average American chick
why is it like this and my second
question was why are men complaining
about marriage so these are men we're
gonna give them smiley face he's saying
they're saying don't ever get married
and I'm thinking why so then my next
question was why don't men want to get
married what I found out is that the
court the legal system all of society is
catering towards women okay all of
society is basically pandering and
simping for women for example in the UK
If You Accuse your guy of a you get a
free lawyer another example is free
government handouts for women in single
month for single mothers so we
essentially have a system that is paying
women to be single mothers so when I
would look at why are women so bad it's
like okay if you pay women to be
terrible then you're probably going to
have more terrible women I mean it's
just common sense if you get paid to be
a single mother why wouldn't you break
up your family well I mean morals but
that's a whole nother and a whole nother
thing so so what I figured out when I
started talking to some of these
politicians right we're going to do this
the guy is a politician he's got a bow
tie yeah that's a bow tie now the issue
is that the politicians the only way
they can get elected the women vote for
them so the reason we can't see a change
in these laws
um you know where men can't get access
to their children where single mothers
are being paid to be single mothers all
of these horrible policies is because
the politicians can't change them
because they won't be re-elected and
then I started researching it further
and I started to think does every person
deserve the right to vote should every
should every person deserve the right to
vote and what I found out is that men
are fined three hundred thousand dollars
if they don't enroll in Selective
Service where women have no skin in the
game and in the U.S anyways we're voting
for a commander-in-chief so is it really
fair that if I vote for a president
because of my feelings say no he's so
mean I'm not gonna name presidents and
instead I vote for somebody that's
basically senile and we go to war is it
fair that the men have to pay for that
bad decision because essentially we have
a society where men are just paying for
women's bad decisions men pay the
majority of the taxes so who's paying
for these women to be single mothers uh
men pay the majority of alimony and
child support payments so again the men
are paying for the women to leave
um men build most of the inventions that
allowed women to go to work so the
Roomba the vacuum cleaner the washing
cleaner men invented it so women could
leave their home and leave little Timmy
at home and now we have we see the
byproduct of this where we have a more
free Society but guys our mental health
is crazy out here everybody's you know
got depression anxiety all this stuff
because women are raising the children
by themselves and single father homes
have better outcomes than single mother
homes but the best outcomes is the
parents together and because our whole
society is pandering to women voting and
getting money from women because women
make 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions so we live in a society that's
just constantly telling us what we want
to hear all of the time we've basically
been brainwashed for the last hundred
years to think that women can really be
equal to men but the truth of the matter
is is that men run Society they run all
of the industries that make Society run
the only reason that women out earn men
is because we can monetize Beauty and
men have subsidized Industries so men
pay their taxes and the government takes
their taxes to make companies have
quotas for women where they're not as
productive as men okay now we have a
whole system where women have been told
what we want to hear our whole lives and
the people that suffer are the children
now I'm a reasonable gal I can maybe get
behind net taxpayers or something but
only if we get rid of all these
subsidies for women because I'm really
tired of women being paid to leave their
husbands I'm really tired of women
um take divorcing their husband taking
office and accusing him of on the way
out I'm tired of this [__] and I'm sorry
but the more power us as women have had
the more we have used it to basically
legally use them you know what I don't
think women should vote that's my
opinion I could also maybe get behind a
net taxpayer and I think if we're going
to vote then equally enroll in the
military and do all of the dangerous
jobs in society go be a plumber go be an
electrician go do all of the hard jobs
and if you don't want to do that maybe
you should just quit whining so that's
you know that's my opinion but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm just crazy you
know I don't know like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time